uh
hello today i'm going to talk about uh
diving into c plus plus internal so fire
address
so as it has been already said my name
is fedor and
i'm working on my address and sometimes
on node.js and eventually i think we're
going to work on node.js again
uh yeah so this is a qr code of this
slideshow and the link
so if you would like to follow it while
i will be speaking you could
feel free to open it and play with it
a bit okay darwin intercepts plus
internals of i or jess
and also it has an alternative title
that i would like to
speak about too and this is a history of
a git blame
okay c plus plus talk on a javascript
conference
this guy must be mad why javascript
developer would be interested in this
but
like anyone cares about it or writing
simple plus a lot here
but in fact if you ever tried to
optimize your javascript code to squeeze
out
every possible performance improvement
or memory stage improvement
from it you are most likely already
written some simple source code
many blog posts workshops mention ways
to optimize javascript and some of the
suggestions are to avoid creating
properties
on the instances of objects in runtime
it is
also called avoid hidden classes when
speaking about v8 at least
and in case of following this suggestion
you usually
declare the properties in the
constructor of the class
and it looks really similar to the
simples plus because in c plus plus you
always
put the properties in the declaration of
the class or the structure
second suggestion is to avoid
polymorphism
or in simpler words to
have to avoid having different types of
values as in
variables or arguments as a function in
this example i have a
function called at and it just performs
additional two numbers and if i will
pass
numbers to it like very often it will be
optimized for the case of numbers
but if i suddenly decide to once pass
even once
to pass the strings to it it will be
optimized and the compiler will
eventually generate the code that we
that will support both cases for strings
and numbers so in the general case that
i'm using here is numbers it will be a
bit slower
so here is a suggestion a white
polymorphism and it's really similar to
c plus plus
because you always declare types here
well almost always
and third suggestion is to cache
and reuse objects that are expensive to
create
we do it in a node.jsi address we do it
for parser for http parser because it's
quite a bit expensive to create because
it goes from javascript to c plus plus
back to the javascript so we cache its
instances
and reuse them once they are needed
again
works like a charm and uh yeah of course
it's oh of course it's the same in the c
plus plus because you
and allocate memory manually here in
most of the cases
so to conclude first javascript is
practically very similar to c plus plus
so i put here a double equals because of
this
io and node.js use cnc plus plus a lot
internally if you didn't know about
and then the reason for this is that v8
is written in c plus it has c plus plus
apis
simple splash headers and stuff like
that so if you will ever need to use it
you will most likely need to
use either some wrapper or write cpus
plus code
and the second reason is that it
provides only ecmascript apis which are
pretty limited
because of sandboxing but it's kind of
cool unless you need timers or file
system api or networking
yeah so this is why we have node.js
sequels plus player
and this simple splash layer lives on
top of the event loop which is provided
by libby
and c plus plus layer provides net
sockets dns queries
apis from file system to zlip bindings
and lots of other stuff coming back to
alternative title history of get blame i
would like to suggest
learning subject by learning its history
and luckily not just is using git
science at the beginning so the history
of everything that we have ever done
with c plus plus in the
is in the output of the git lock and git
blame
in particular if you look at the output
of git log dip suite you will see
the history of v8 fighting us and it
looks received history of us fighting
the v8
okay node.js begins not exactly like
this but
with this commit and commit lock says
add readme and initial code
unfortunately i can't really elaborate
much from this
so i i did check out it
not yesterday but close to it and figure
out that they had two c plus plus
dependencies except v8
one was sleep ebb a weird name right
uh and dbb was a http server on top of
the event loop for robbies that ryan
dahl has
written before the node.js but now it
was used that that commits only four
parts since http
so not much but i guess he wanted to
stay in his comfort zone
second dependency is leap or i which
stands for library for output input
and it was used to create tcp server and
it was running
on top of the lbv so it's kind of
implicit dependency so i didn't mention
it in this list
here is how the first ever javascript
user code
looked like for node.js it was just a
single global
process function which accepted a
request argument that it was performing
some stuff
but how was it organized internally
there was a server.cc file
cc is an extension for c plus sometimes
it's
cpp uh and this file was used for
command line arguments parsing um for
initializing javascript for initializing
the v8 and loading euro code from the
first argument executing it and then
execution
flown to the jshprequestprocessor.cc
this file created http server and was
invoking this process function for every
incoming request
almost nothing was working at this point
so when i built it i tried to execute it
it was
throwing errors all over the way but i
i after some tweaking i was able to run
it and it was reported in the
incoming uri so it was just a proof of
the concept
summary of what we could see in that
version
there was one file to set up create and
call online arguments
sheetp error was in c plus without
any networking events emitted in
javascript or any
you know complex stuff that we have
right now
and there was one simple splash instance
for every incoming http request
this is a kind of important because this
way it provided the mapping
from the c plus plus instance to
javascript object it was set in uri
headers and methods
on javascript object and it was kind of
mapping to the c plus plus instance
this is the pattern that we are going to
use and we are using this right now too
so this is important to note now we
quickly jump to next commit
commit lock says use object rep base
class for file socket and server
much better now so this means
there is one api now to wrap all the
objects
and the nic in this api rows because
there are now net server net socket file
that are all uh
the simplest classes that are mapped to
the javascript objects so they
need to be mapped in some way and to
duplicate the code we created
object trap well actually they created
without me i wasn't
doing any stuff at that point but anyway
file structure that commit was following
there was crc slash not dot cc file
which initialized c plus plus libraries
and then it invoked
crc slash main.js you see uh
here emerges important patterns that we
are going to use even now
we are separating the consorts so it's
kind of
usual scene we try to do as much as
possible in javascript in a simpler
scripting language that can't crash uh
kill your program
and it's only the rest and stuff that we
can do in the javascript we do in c
plus plus so it is now executing sir c
slash my index.js and this file loads
user code
this file compiles it and executes it
and calls
everything that happens in user code
another file in c plus plus is serious
http.cc
it provides http server api connection
and http request classes crc slash
file.ccsrc
file.js is a future fs module
crc slash process.cc has only exit
method right now
and it will eventually become a future
process object that we have now
crc timers.cc provides just set them out
and set interval
so nothing surprising here uh just a
side note
http server is still provided by leap oi
and node.js is using libby for event
loop and asynchronous networking
quickly jump into version 0.2 we see
that it has grown a lot
uh measure it a bit and there was large
movement in separating javascript from c
plus plus here
so in the previous version there was
still some stuff in c-class part that
could be done in javascript
and now we separated this almost
everywhere
where we can now node.js is using
command.js
for both userland modules and for
internal modules and core modules
and we have introduced tons of new core
modules in this version
file structure is following we now
separate this stuff in the
leap folder for all javascript core
modulus and crc folder for the
c plus plus contour parts um just in
case dependencies
live in a depth folder and this folder
has ever seen from v8
parsers crs for dns leap eio for
asynchronous file system and libv for
networking and event loop object reps
that we previously
seen that it was only immersion and was
just created now it is a public api
and the community and the core team
members has polished it out a lot and
it became much greater because of the
community too
previously all siplesplus classes were
exposed to the javascript user code as a
global object
so it was kind of messy internal stuff
was visible everywhere but
since we are now using command.js we
decided to
move them in a secret place
uh which is process.building so
when you call it with let's say a first
string
it will return binding with this name
and this binding contains just
several functions and several classes
every class and every function is mapped
to some simplesplus instance so it's
one to one maybe yeah and
it's pretty similar for other modulars
too if you would try to call it
uh okay quickly jump into version 0.6
now
and uh what happened here the most
important thing is that libya was a libv
and leap eio was replaced by libya this
was possible only because of lots of
work by ben
north hughes bird builder ryan dahl and
other people
which i'm really thankful for and uh it
is a
major milestone for node.js because we
now have a windows support in it
all because of dbv quickly jump into
0.10 we could say probably only one
thing
uh it was boring but a bit stable
so we jumped to zero to 12 on io.js and
there are
lots of new stuff that we are interested
in in c plus plus this stock
important thing to say now we are no
longer using object rep internally
and this is why it's important to learn
the history because if we take a look at
it now it will be
seem unreasonable to you we are using a
syncrep
class instead and the reason uh the
difference between them is that
a syncrep has two uh fields that object
cloud didn't have
one of them as parent and second is
provider type a provider type is
basically saying
what this c plus plus class instance is
used for
for example it could be file system dns
tcp or that leap and parent
says a point could be another syncrep
and says
uh how this syncrop instance that you're
looking at was created
example if you have http server and in
request handler you
do a synchronous fs right it will create
a new sync wrap
and this async wrap for fs.write will
have a parent
uh will have http request as a parent of
it so if you will walk
from this assembly up to its parent you
will see sort of
you could build a waterfall like in a
fire bug or something like this to
figure out
what happened why happened and what kind
of stuff
happens in your application this is a
part of the tracing apis that is still
and works
but i think it will eventually be
available
in a simple way to the users
okay we have arrived now at the point
the present point of the node.js in io
address so it's time
to stop the software archaeology and
learn some real stuff so it's time to
get into simples plus internals
and we'll talk about interoperation
handles
reps and maybe unicorns uh
yeah so there are two folders now except
dependencies
leap and crc and there are two folders
that we are interested in
when you call require fs
it does nothing but just loads leap
slash dot fs
uh leave slash fs.gs and executes it so
there is no magic happening here
but no magic means that there is no fs
operations to write because js is not
capable
uh offer phase operations by itself so
it isn't capable of networking either
and
it's for the best believe me because of
sandboxing because you don't want the
chromium to
ruin your file system or crack
ssh servers somewhere but if you need
a fs write file sync http request
you probably need lots of simple stuff
outside of the js land
to figure out how it all plays together
and how
things are calling each other i would
like to suggest to learn by example
though uh recur office is kind of boring
because it works just with the
numbers you know file descriptor is just
a number when you open file
kernel is returning number and you pass
number again plus the number is kind of
boring
so let's move to recur net
and it does follow in stuff it creates
circuits obviously
it needs connect events when you
when a connection is established and it
supports writes and supports
meet and write callbacks and all of this
is powered by c plus plus machinery so
we are really interested in this
so how does leap slash dot slash fs.js
gets this c stuff by process.bini as we
already
talked about and the buildings that we
are interested in
are tcp underscore app which lives in
crc slash
tcp underscore web.cc and stream rep
these buildings provide following
javascript classes tcp
tsp connect wrap write wrap and shutdown
wrap
purpose of this class is following tcp
holds
the socket itself and it has methods to
perform
reads and writes on it and the rep
is something that you pass in
to the tcp instance when you want to do
some asynchronous stuff
so it's kind of request i don't know
so i promised you an example net connect
works in the following way
first a tcp instance is created
remember tcp is actually a javascript
class that is mapped to c plus plus
class so it's invoking internals of
node.js
then it stores tcp in underscore handle
of the net socket
i think probably raise your hand if you
know what's underscore handler if you've
ever seen it
no one's in okay yeah so uh if you ever
used
nets api directly net socket has
underscore handle property and this one
points to simple plus instance of tcp
class
then it is parsing arguments to the net
connect
as you probably remember net connect
accepts
port callback signature or support host
callback
and options callbacks so it's there are
several ways to pass
the options that you want to use for
connection to it and it needs to put
them in separate variables to simplify
how it works with c plus plus
then it creates the rep stuff that i was
talking about so it creates tcp connect
wrap
and it's calling it's called tcp connect
rec port
host and then once c plus plus internals
will connect to the host using the event
loop and a kernel it will
invoke request dot on complete so this
is why we need the request because we
would like to
send a notification to the javascript
code when the
action is completed so tcp socket
usually leaves more than
the rep so the conclusion handles
is like tcp there are two types of
classes sorry handles it's like tcp udp
even that leap is a handle reps are
requests
so it's a sync request verb and reps
leave
much shorter than the handle instances
because you usually connect only once a
circuit to perform right before closing
the circuit
and stuff like that file structure
now looks like this crc slash
tcp underscore wrap.cc has tcp rep jsp
connect wrap
and stream base and io.js and now it
will be in node.js2 eventually
has a right wrap and shutdown wrap and
it's structured in the following way but
to figure out how the structure is
simple plus we need to ask ourselves
we need to go from the point where
javascript is starting to interact with
the c-plus plus and it's starting to
interact from process.bin
so how does these siplus plus files that
i was talking about
tell javascript that they have some
bindings to provide
they use following a macro a
construction in c plus plus code so if
you will
clone the io address or an address
project and noble simplest
file you will see node module contacts
the wearable thing at the very bottom of
it and it tells two things first
is the name of the binding is it is the
same string that you pass
to the process.binion function and
second is the function that this will be
used for installation process
and it has kind of the same effect as
following javascript called snippet
so just puts the binding onto some kind
of internal hashmap in c plus plus
and sets initialization function here
so when you call process.binning it does
nothing but just
following javascript code it just gets
the binding from the hashmap
and initialized it if it wasn't
initialized yet
so what this installation function does
it
installates the model
yeah so it does similar things that
happen in common.js
when you recur current model is actually
executed only once and then the result
is cached
so this module module gets export
subjects as an argument
and simplest passcode is just putting
various methods and simplesplus classes
on this object
so when process.binning is called and it
returns with
an object as we seen in uh very first
slides about the fs module
okay so with export function first yeah
each exported
javascript class has a c plus control
part so it has some class declaration
with um
most likely similar name in c plus plus
and you could always figure out
which class it is related to by just
looking at that name and
figure out where the binding lives in a
crc folder
most of these c plus classes are
actually
inherited from the async wrap
so they have kind of similar structure
and similar apis
internally okay uh before i go further
just small reminders that there are two
kind of classes handle and reps
handlers like tsp reps it's stuff that
you pass when you want to connect all
right
and certainly when you work with a
javascript engine when you map c plus
plus classes to javascript objects you
should consider how this stuff will be
interacting with a garbage collector in
fact
there are two different types of
interactions that we have in node.js
one is to let the garbage collector
destroy stuff and this is what happens
to handles when the they are closed when
you close the tcp socket
it will be destroyed only when the v8
garbage collector would
will decide to do this thing
on other hand requests are manually
destroyed by the c plus plus code so
there is no need to wait for the jc
to collect them and they are destroyed
right after the
sync action completion so once rick
doton completes its called
i think it's destroyed and it's not
available anymore
okay i guess you're pretty scared by now
yeah
time to test your skills
situation let's say that you debug
ios issue and uh for example io js is
crashing on some code that you wrote or
you see in kernel
or in core modules and this code looks
like this
so it just gets the bindian with the
name for bar gets a full bar class out
of it
and then uh it crashes when you try to
instantiate the
football class so the question is where
will you search for a foobar
okay uh you don't have a microphone
anyway so i will answer the question
myself
you will try to search somewhere in crc
folder because this is a folder where
all the simplest plus stuff of node.js
leaves and you will
most likely will want to search for the
node module context availability
things that we were talking about
because it's the way the binding tells
about itself to the javascript and
most likely this file will be named crc
full
underscore bar dot cc or something like
this so it will most likely have a
similar name to the meaning name
okay i guess i have some time yeah i
have one
not much so i'd like to talk about
my one of my recent obsessions and this
is simple streams
this is what we are trying to figure out
and i address right now
and would like to make it public
eventually
and the reason i would like to talk
about it is because uh
i want it to be public and
when things become public they are
usually polished out by community a lot
and improved
and the api got improved and stuff is
getting better
we did it for object wrap and the
results was fantastic
and i think we should do it for the
streams in c plus plus
and the streams the stream rep which is
actually base class for the tcp udp and
stuff like that
it wasn't that bad in 0.10 not just
actually
but it was modified a lot for 0.12
because we moved tls ssl implementation
into c plus plus to make it faster
so it now looks terrible in 0.12.
and there are several several reasons
why i think
this is terrible first of all because we
wanted to
move tls to the simplest plus from the
javascript we need
some way to work with the data that's
coming from circuit and the data to come
as it comes to circuit in the simplest
path without invoking any javascript
events for performance reasons
and um because we want this we did some
sort of
redirecting of the output input to the
callbacks
you see callback stuff so it supports
only one depth nesting so it doesn't
support redirecting
two times or three times so it's kind of
not good uh and it uh may skip
javascript callbacks altogether
for example if uh tls protocol is
performing a handshake process where it
sends certificate of the server and
replies to this
with some crypts crazy stuff
it doesn't really invoke any javascript
callbacks yet because there is no
connection to talk about
uh yet and it does some black magic
inside
which is not great too but performance
is really fantastic
source code is rigid
but when i think about it when i thought
about it i
was keeping in mind that javascript
streams that we have for quite a long
time now
and they work pretty well when
except when they doesn't they support
multi-level piping
and this sort of piping is really
transparent to the user so you could
pipe
let's say tcp socket to a tls protocol
implementation and pipe this to
maybe a speedy protocol implementation
and then get the outputs in the right of
that stream and everything will work
by magic but it's easy to debug and
figure out
most of the cases so the questions that
i asked myself
myself what uh was what if we could do
the same thing
in io.js and this is what we did for the
stream base
uh for stream streams in c plus plus and
we called it in stream base
so it supports um
no it doesn't have spooky callbacks
instances so it's just
one stream based class and you could uh
pipe
output or an input to another stream
based class so it's really
singular i don't know in some sense
which is uh
much better than previously so it
supports multi-level consumption so we
could implement multiple protocols in c
plus plus and
pipe them together or in terminology or
stream based can consume them
and um it has almost no black magic
right now
it's quite much simpler than it was
and performance is the same so it's
great
still there is some stuff that needs to
be done in order to make it public
and this is uh following we need
to implement a way to unconsume and pipe
the stream base from another stream
because we have similar stuff in
javascript and i guess
some people may want to do it in the
cpus too and
apis still needs to be cleaned up a bit
so let's make it public that's what i
want at least
because it's cool because it has great
performance
balls in core and i guess it will have a
same performance in user land because
you could
avoid javascript altogether and http 2
could be implemented
on top of it and would will have really
amazing performance
and the last reason that users know
better how this code should look like
because
we did this for users and
uh yeah they know better okay some
stuff that i would like to suggest you
to look take a look at
if we will ever want to dig in the
simplest plus internal so i suggest you
to clone the io address or notice
repo open crc folder go through files
here
check what you learned fix if we are run
somewhere or
perhaps if we wrote some code that
doesn't look right to you
send a pull request to us and have fun
yeah that's it thank you
all right so questions
there's a question over here second word
hello hi thank you for your presentation
um
i have a two questions uh first is about
libya and javascript event loop
if you refer to uh libya recommendation
we can see it has a trade pool of fixed
size by default s4 and
it's for specific kind of
workload is for file operations
dns operations and documentation set
a user code
javascript event loop and we straight
pull
how we relate to each other does the
code we write to your js
run under whis to pull or not
and the second question is about i think
reps
i know there are some undercommented
features like
process underscore get active handles
and process underscore get active
requests
is it one one-to-one binding or
it is another kind of things
okay we'll answer the first question uh
so there was
indeed a threadball in dbv and uh
this thread pull isn't actually used for
anything except the
file system stuff and networking stuff
like that so it's just
for this i guess eventually javascript
will run on some sort of thread pool too
and we did lots of work in uh node.js
and io.js like preliminary work for this
so there is support for running
in threads but it's unfinished yet and i
guess um
as far as i remember there was a pull
request or issue on ios repos that
was mentioning uh creating some sort of
lightweight
threads that wasn't sort of like web
workers and browsers right
so when this will come out
of the github it will be available for
users but for now
the threat will runs only for
internal ebv stuff and for
simplest loss bindings that the user
sort so if they for example wrote the
bin
for the database like mysql
or something like this the they could
choose
the simplest stuff to run on the thread
pull
this is possible and do it simple space
but it's not possible in javascript yet
could i please ask you about the second
question because i don't think that i
got it right sorry
it's about uh i think wraps yeah yeah
and uh
undocumented features on process like
underscore get active requests and get
active handles
do it relate to each other or not okay
yeah uh
it is related but not always
it's probably the simplest uh answers
that i can give you uh so not every
async wrap
object has a
actual ep handle that performs some
asynchronous stuff
so for example that leap well not the
uh it might be might be hard to get an
example of top of my head
okay so basically process.get dot
underscore get active handles returns
the active leap uv handles and not every
sync wrap instance has a libya handle
associated with it because it's
very very generic and it does nothing
but just mapping
from the c plus plus to the javascript
object so it doesn't necessarily need to
have
some libya stuff in it yeah so
it's not necessarily not necessarily
this and tracing apis that will be
introduced will work probably in some
another way
it was actually uh probably one of the
main reasons why 0.12 was delayed
because we tried to figure out how this
trace and api was working so
we haven't we just removed it
but yeah okay
more questions can see anyone
[Music]
okay can we pass the mic over there
oh yeah you were saying on twitter sorry
i could not hear you
okay let's see about that
um what do you think about the new
javascript engine
microsoft called chakra
nothing
[Laughter]
i seen a microsoft slash notes
repository but
it came out at the time when uh
we was traveling so i didn't have a
really
good internet connection i was able to
clone it and play with it
in particular i know nothing about its
implementation yet
but i will definitely take a look so if
you have
if you want to hear something more than
thoughts you could probably email me
and uh yeah my email is kind of public
sync and
should be easy to figure out by just
first and last name
so i was wondering if we're going to get
political here
and we're totally going to uh are you
glad you hit the fork button
are you in favor of reconciliation with
node
my vote was zero on this
the reason is uh that
i probably don't have a special opinion
as long as
as long as we can shape the releases
regularly
so if we want there is no nothing to
prevent us
from forking it again but
yeah i think it should be fine for now
i'm pretty impressed with the activity
that we have an old foundation and i'm
pretty
impressed with the stuff that guys
prepared
for us to reconcile so i'm very
optimistic about it right now
i think we've established a rally and
where that it's going to be called
whatever it's called today
js um we'll see about that
and another question political question
if official iojs merges with node again
what do you think it will mean for the
governance model
uh i don't think that anything is going
to change
i'm not really really like lawyer and
political guy and i i wasn't
one that like
puts all this stuff together with
governance it was the michael and
probably other people um but
i guess nothing should be changed
otherwise i don't see why
people was so happy about it
okay any more questions from the
audience since we are political right
now
so any uncomfortable oh there is an
uncomfortable question right there
thank you
just shout
um we switch the topics chakra
and in the same direction what is your
opinion about
the javascript core or the nitro from
apple
because that's also implemented in cc
plus plus and i
play around with the optics c api
and i have the problem that the same
what you're talking about
you don't have anything no no no network
no timeout et cetera
and for me uh it's interesting
it's easy to port the node
the plus plus code in this direction
yeah it should be possible um well
there are two at least two reasons for
this first of all microsoft did this for
chakra
and second reason is some guy did it for
spider monkey and as far as i remember
he just
provided a wrapper that looked like
v8 api so he created a header
for the spider monkeys that looked
essential like va does so nodes just
wasn't given anything about it so it
just was using it uh generally i
am really impressed by the javascript
core because like i'm
a bit of a compiler junkie too and they
have
as far as three compilers one is
interpreter
and the second is unoptimized and third
is optimized code so it's
kind of very it was always very
interesting to me
i guess it's it depends on your needs so
that's probably the right answer if you
need to have whole node.js api
then i would suggest to try making the
v8 headers and pretending that
the javascript course that you have is
actually v8 for an andreas
and it should be possible but if you
don't need all this stuff you could
probably try to
have some sort of minimal core with just
libya v
and it will probably serve you needs as
well as
yeah pretending yeah that's it thanks
um so i think we're done with questions
we're going to have
lunch in a second i'm personally pretty
excited
about like the merging back of like iojs
to note i feel like
the breaking up kind of had to happen in
a way so
now we can collaborate better so i don't
know there was a little bit of drama for
a little bit but now i think we're
better off
uh with that and some better like
collaboration tools in place like i'm
really impressed with how like
uh all the tc meetings are going for
iojs and releases are
great so i'm i'm excited i hope everyone
else is excited as well um
thank you for for this awesome deep dive
talk and uh
we will have lunch now for an hour and a
half so uh
everyone enjoy the food
you